[Music]
what do you make of the alright that
everybody's talking about right now do
you I don't think you consider yourself
part of it you're sort of I do not
you're a you're a parcel to it or
something like that right like because
they're they're getting some tool or
something like that like they're getting
I think I think some of the techniques
that they're doing of upsetting people
in power with memes you know you have so
nobody in the basement they send out a
Nazi meme to somebody important that
person retweets it thus you're showing
that you're upsetting them and you're
changing the game from your basement
like some of that seems like the stuff
that you're talking about well first of
all i disavow the alter is what I said
you spy you endorse Trump or dying I'm
putting you in the alright disavowed
Trump i disavow everybody just hillary
clinton because that that's best for my
personal safety yes i don't even know
what the the you know the alt-right even
is isn't it like a grab bag of
miscellaneous things that other people
don't like thanks pretty much what i
described it at the beginning of this
yes if polite people don't like it it's
in so I'm not sure how one you know can
can love that movement but it certainly
is having an impact yeah but it's using
the techniques you're talking about
right like they're doing a lot of elites
that they're upsetting people in power
everybody's using the techniques some
are using better than others
and yes I would say that I've observed
them intentionally trying to use the the
power the tools of persuasion but both
sides are doing that now yeah I'm
curious because you become so big on
Twitter and you have your base on
Twitter that that absolutely loves you
do you ever find that they're leading
you do you ever find that you're about
to tweet something and go I have this
could this could upset them or they'll
get confused or or as someone that's
that's a writer and that's able to get a
thought out in a you know six panel
cartoon but Twitter has some drawbacks
when you're trying to really formulate a
thought I all communication has
drawbacks and I definitely I'm
definitely informed by who's reading my
tweets to keep them in a someone that
you know makes sense for the Fall
but beyond that I'm big proponent of
free speech so I'm not gonna I'm not
going to mute myself totally yeah I have
what I lovingly recall [ __ ] you money so
I don't know I don't have a boss
I don't need to I don't need to make
other people happy if I have something
that needs to be said I can do that yeah
you don't have to tell me the number but
when did you realize you had [ __ ] you
money 10 years ago probably all right so
let's do a little bit on Hillary because
we kind of danced around her a bit it's
sort of all it's all encompassing this
is the talk Trump you're sort of talking
Hillary already we're just stuck in this
thing what do you make of her do you
think it seems just uninspiring to me
and I consider her as much of a liar as
I consider Trump and we're just screwed
how's that for me how's that for a lead
I'll tell you at this point in the race
if you're gonna vote for the one who's
not the liar good luck you know I think
there was a there was a point early on
in the race where you could say Trump is
lying way more than Clinton but I think
that difference has been erased and the
reason is that lying worked really
really well
mm-hmm and so Clinton is sort of as I
said earlier dispensed with the facts
and she's more about he's a racist and
misogynist and I don't think as I've
said I think that's confirmation bias
it's not fact but the the race has
almost entirely if you think about it
it's I've never seen this before the
race has gone from talking about
policies and things in the world to
almost entirely talking about this gray
lump of matter in each of their heads
mm-hmm like that you know is is is
Hillary's sick or lying or whatever is
Trump you know crazy racist misogynist
or whatever but it's all about the gray
thing in their skull like what about the
world right so was that the obvious
outcome here in a weird way if you if
you go back six months and you really
saw what was gonna happen here and you
look at Hillary and go a Bernie actually
they were gonna take him down no matter
what and if you saw what Trump was
building which as you said you saw it a
little earlier than most people in a way
this was the obvious we were gonna get
to this right no matter what
probably the gravity was sucking us to
this place yes the the only unknown was
whether Hillary would go as dark as she
went by the way that we're dark probably
came from Godzilla that's that's an
engineered word that's the word they
don't hear in politics which is designed
to attract confirmation by us hey
everything Trump is doing is dark now
don't even regard for people that missed
the beginning of that clip that's that
what's the guy's name again
so that would be Robert chill Dini I'm
just hypothesizing I don't have
confirmation yeah that he's working on
the Clinton campaign advising her in the
persuasion arts yeah okay so let's put
Trump and Clinton aside for a second and
I want to finish up with free speech
because that's sort of been the thrust
of everything that I do here and I know
it's something that's obviously very
important to you what do you make of a
state of free speech in America in 2016
as a creator as someone that puts
thoughts out there and you do poke fun
at a lot of our societal nonsensical
ways that we self censor yeah it's it's
interesting in many ways the world is
going in the same direction in the sense
that there's more of everything I mean I
think in the old days more of something
than less of something else but now
there are more places that you could
speak with complete freedom you know
online mm-hmm but there and then there
are fewer places that you could do the
same thing in corporate America or in
other places so in some ways there's
more freedom than ever but in a whole
lot of places in troubling ways there's
less than ever I'm a little on the fence
about how much of that is bad and how
much of is good because I do think that
words matter and I think that there are
places where you know civil conversation
is more important than say in your mind
right freedom of speech is overrated in
some contexts but you certainly have to
have it to have an effective government
and effective country right so to that
and do you say ask them bringing it back
to Trump unfortunately here but I have
to for the purposes of that do you think
that once in office if he became
president do you think he'd be able to
have those conversations
in that sort of space where he's not
doing these all these tricks but doing I
suspect your answers yes well I think if
you imagine a president Trump I could
see two things happening once is that
everybody moderates once they get the
job I remember back in my corporate days
you know one of my co-workers would get
promoted to an important level of
responsibility and their personality
would just change overnight right I'd
start getting serious and they would
stop joking around
certainly Trump would be doing some of
that right so there would be some
moderation just because the job
imagine I'm just imagine yourself you
know you're no matter what you're
thinking before you walk into the Oval
Office right you walk into the Oval
Office you're in the White House all
right there's no way that doesn't change
it's real now it's real that's the
biggest influence you could have in fact
chill Deena even writes about this the
influence of your physical environment
in his new book which I'll plug for him
he's pre suasion pre - suasion will be
the the biggest book about persuasion
the world's ever seen
it'll be massive I got an early copy so
I saw yes so Trump will moderate just
because the physical you know power of
the office well also he's also created
in everybody's mind and expectation that
he does things that other people don't
so if you're let's say you know that the
heads of China or Russia and Trump says
a you know crazy thing that people don't
normally say they're not gonna say oh my
god here comes to the nukes they're
gonna they're gonna say that's what he
does that's what yeah yeah yeah so we
have to stop thinking that China is a
bunch of idiots they're gonna
misconstrue what's happening over here
it could not be more clear than the
Trump says things other people don't say
so if he does more of it people are
gonna say well there's more of it right
so basically they would just have to
learn how to readjust already have I
mean I think that process is done yeah
you know you just have to see enough of
him to say okay he's talking like I'm
gonna say a New Yorker and we get that
yeah you know once you get the that
that's his style you're okay with it
yeah I think it's interesting what you
said about how so in some ways it feels
like we have less free speech
and in some ways it feels like we have
more because people have now used the
internet to do this there's some I'm a
little caught between feeling that the
internet side of it is good and bad
because so many people are doing it
anonymously that I feel like they're
they're exercising their right to free
speech but then it also comes with you
say all kinds of things that you would
never say in person I have no problem
with what they say as I say all the time
I show I don't like the Nazi memes and
showing all these you know raise actual
racist things about black people
whatever I wouldn't stop them from doing
it but I guess but still you would say
that's a net good because at least
there's the outlet yeah I would say that
anonymity is essential in a free society
you got to be able to say some things
anonymously mm-hmm
but I also say that the cure for all the
bad stuff is sunlight and the more of
the anonymous people say horrible things
the more of the sunlight starts to you
know eroded so I think you have to let
it out before you can kill it
yeah so to that point would you if
someone was tweeting you all day and
sending you awful Nazi memes or any of
this you mean my entire day so my policy
is I just ignore them occasionally I
mute them and on a very rare occasion if
they just won't stop then I'll block
them but I never amplify them because I
feel like well if I don't really pretend
that they're here then unless they you
know what I mean like they're not
outside with pitchforks they're just
doing it from the comfort of their own
computer do you basically think that
that's a good policy in this way because
otherwise I feel like we're just making
their ideas bigger if every time if I
get outraged that they sent me something
upsetting and then I outraged somebody
else by retweeting it you know then it
becomes this never-ending thing I feel
like I'm judging everyone individually
because every once a while they'll say
something that links to some data yeah
and now look at that and say that's data
that I mean now maybe I don't like where
their implication or where a heads or
any of that mm-hmm
but data's data so those I tend to let
stay but if somebody just comes on and
yells some racial
you know stuff then I usually just walk
them right away yeah all right final
thought you've already predicted it say
you're predicting a trump landslide do
you want to give me some percentages you
want to put yourself out there to that I
said some from last year 98% Trump
landslide and hasn't changed what has
changed is that he's had terrible weeks
and if that week was the only thing that
happened until the end of course he
would lose but that never stays the same
there weeks are gonna be up and down I
think there are some big shocks to come
I think that all the Trump shocks are
baked in was almost nothing you could
hear about him you know totally out of
left field that would make any
difference right but there's a whole
bunch of stuff you could hear about
Clinton especially since she has a
government experience right that that
makes her more vulnerable to a shock
because if you did it in the context of
government it seems worse mm-hmm so that
alone I think almost guarantees a trump
victory really so basically that
WikiLeaks could just drop something
because we know they're holding
something doesn't even have to be
WikiLeaks could be anything could be
anything
well I've thoroughly enjoyed talking to
you and I'm glad we were able to talk
about some of this stuff without sort of
the craziness attached to it because
doesn't it feel like it's just crazy all
the time right crazy in the most
entertaining ways yeah I have never had
a more fun year of my life I gotta say I
wake up put everybody happy because the
news is going to entertain me and and
people are people are people are engaged
yeah he engage with the engagement look
at look what people learned about their
government this year about how the
primaries work you know that they are
rigged a little bit I mean that just the
level of human engagement is off the
chart and I would go so far as to say
that a president Trump would probably
encourage more direct public
participation because it just feels like
he needs it clean because he just loves
it he loves that well I think Clinton
would do her thing and her lobbyists
would write her write legislation and be
like always but if you saw a president
Trump you think almost anything was
possible so you'd say I got an idea and
people are already you sending me all
these ideas for building the border wall
with a with a light rail train on the
top
businesses and casinos and you know
making it a you know economic zone a
good guy we're here we're hearing all
this big thinking on one side and I feel
like something's being unleashed in a
good way like a creative thing and we
hope it's not the you know not some kind
of race war all right well for more on
Scott and the Dilbert cartoon and his
thoughts and blog and all that you can
check out blog Dilbert com thanks for
watching and we will do it again next
week
[Music]